this is an 8 news now breaking news
alert
thank you for joining us i'm john
langler we start with this breaking at
noon about 15 minutes ago the regional
justice center in downtown las vegas
reopened a bomb threat forced its
evacuation though earlier this morning
this over at lewis and third downtown
christian kazarus is there live with the
latest information christian good
afternoon
john good afternoon metro police telling
us about an hour ago that that bomb
threat was issued here at the regional
justice center but we just got word that
that bomb threat has been lifted take a
look here at the situation here live at
this hour now we're currently on the
southeast corner specifically over on
bonneville and third right now which is
just about a block south from the
courthouse now what we know at this hour
is that we know there was an evacuation
that took place just a short time ago as
a precaution for what the rjc calls a
safety clearance protocol now i spoke to
the rjc public information officer just
a few minutes ago and she tells me that
the building was given orders to
evacuate around 10 30 this morning we're
also told that the k9 unit was here on
scene assisting officers during their
efforts now when we pulled up we saw
hundreds of employees including some of
the jurors that were just being escorted
away from the property by metro officers
a few of them we spoke to them and they
were telling us that they were on the
third floor and the u.s marshal came up
to them to notify them about the
evacuation so as you can imagine some
folks were very nervous about what was
happening but overall it was a very
peaceful flow from the employees
as they were walking outside of the
property but again that bomb threat
issued this morning has now been lifted
no other details have been released
by metro police we of course will stay
on scene and bring you any updates as
soon as they happen live as well as
online christian casa is live local now